hello everybody my name is am i
recording yes hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to the test
hypothesis rises uh you guys like the
test and this is the second in a trilogy
of tests to discover the inner secrets
of my being i don't know how this one is
different than the last one
but apparently it is but if it's not
different enough you'll never see this
video it never existed and i'm wiping it
from your memory right now
because apparently this is all leading
up to something and i don't know there's
it's a trilogy so the third one says
that there's some kind of revelations
but this one is still extremely highly
rated so i can only assume that it's a
little different but if it's not
i will be upset before experiencing the
test hypothesis rising it is highly
recommended that you've played the
prequel the test but first before
venturing into this experience
i did that you will stand to gain a lot
more from this experience if you played
the test first and this examination will
also make a bit more sense as it carries
on from where the last examination left
off i would like to urge you to go and
play
i did it i've done it i've already
played the test wonderful news we can
continue
[Music]
hi
it's a little more bloody is that a dead
body hmm
okay fate hello and welcome to my office
it's truly a pleasure to see you here
today
okay
please excuse the mess i haven't had a
chance to clean up yet clean up what i
don't see anything i don't see help on
the walls i don't see a bleedy-eyed
teddy bear i don't see a dead body i
don't see bloodstains all over the floor
i don't see a crack in your bookshelf
and i don't see the skull on your face
now i don't want to take up too much of
your time with blibber blabber and
nonsensical speak so i'll just get
straight to the point
sometimes we have to ask ourselves
life's tough questions there's one
question in particular i'd like to ask
you for you to ask yourself
are you happy
the toughest question of all
i think so and when i say happy i don't
mean content being content is great but
it's not the same as being happy
i want to help you
i want to inspire you to be the best
that you can be
i want to inspire you to be the happiest
version
of yourself
i want to see you grow inside and out
now how do we accomplish this you might
be asking good question allow me to
explain
i'm going to ask you a series of
questions and you were going to answer
them with 100 entire honesty and when i
say 100 entire honesty i mean 100
entire
honesty
think about it
you do want to be happy don't you
you wouldn't want to do something so
bold as to tempt fate by lying would you
just remember if you lie the only person
you're lying to is yourself the only
person who will suffer from this is you
and believe me
you will shuffle
all right
not to mention the fact that whether you
tell the truth or not i'll know but
that's another story let's be moving on
shall we we've wasted enough time
explaining what we're going to be doing
just remember we all want to be good
people we all want to give the answers
that we feel then the most desirable
human traits within ourselves
but sometimes good people do bad things
and sometimes we don't always have
desirable traits as humans
i cannot express enough just how
important it is to be truly honest while
answering these questions no matter how
uncomfortable the truth may make you
well this
this is a slight bit more
preamble and blibber blabber than you
might have anticipated saying now it's
time to get into the real meat of this
experience it's time for you to get the
advice you deserve
as you read questions and scenarios
during this process i want you to create
your own circumstances and build your
own bridges to arrive at the answer that
best suits your own psyche
if you've never experienced the scenario
being asked if you then simply made me i
know this okay
we're going to start with some basic
easy questions and here we
go
if you answer these questions twice your
advice may change it's not just about
answering the questions about many
different variables
many different factors are at play here
including the amount of time taken
answer the proposed questions with that
being said it's far more important to
actually take your time and think about
how honest of an answer you're giving
before you give it
whatever you do do not rush the process
time is your best friend here you'll see
what i mean soon enough
oh
you feel uncomfortable right now i do
just immediately now because of what you
just said
are you nervous i kind of a little bit
do you feel cold
actually i do it's a little chilly in
here which is strange it's usually
sweltering you feel sad nope kind of
nervous
have you ever hurt someone because you
were hurting even if they didn't deserve
it i'm sure i have at some point
i try not to take out my frustrations on
someone else but i can't say that i'm
perfect so i'm i'm sure i have
yes
do you crave acceptance by others
i'm more crave acceptance of myself and
i have already accepted myself i kind of
do whatever the hell i want
it's weird saying this considering i'm a
youtuber and millions of people are
watching this but to be perfectly honest
i do not
i validate my own existence through my
own approval of my own actions so i
don't crave acceptance from others i
crave acceptance of myself no
have you ever lost a loved one yes
do you know what heartbreak feels like
yes
do you believe in demons no
um
do you believe in curses no
would you consider yourself to be
spiritual no
are you afraid of dying alone we
answered this previously
no if there was an undeniable proof that
ghost was haunting you would you
continue to live in your home
i might you know i might actually
be pretty dope to be honest
yeah have you ever seen an object
mysteriously move without being touched
no
do you believe that it's possible for a
game to summon supernatural forces into
your life without knowing it no
would you like to make more friends
ah
not
really
i don't even keep up with the friends i
have no
would you consider yourself to be a good
friend
no i'm bad at being friend i barely
respond to people
no
do you feel lonely no
what was that
do i make friends easily no what about
talk to me what was that talk to me what
was that do you tend to avoid drama
where possible yes
have you ever had a near-death
experience yes
do you like horror movies uh yeah i say
yeah this is all very interesting
i'm sure it is what
what was the words have you played the
test yes that's the spirit
have you played the horoscope no give it
a whack i'm not totally
oh a nice self bro night hashtag ad do
you watch porn yes
would you consider yourself to be a hard
worker
yes
have you do you have a low opinion of
yourself
no would you consider yourself to be a
confident person yes would you help an
old lady across the street even if you
were running late for appointment
absolutely
would you kill all of your neighbors
pets just to save one of your own
what kind of question is that okay so
the scenario i'm imagining is that
chica is in a fight with a neighbor's
dog
and a cat
and a bird they're all attacking chica
so i guess i would myrtlize every one of
those if they were trying to kill chica
and it says save
my own pet i think i would i think if it
came down to it
i think i would
have you ever tried to smother yourself
with a pillow to see if you could
actually suffocate yourself
no
i don't think it would work
i don't think i could to myself i've
never tried that but kind of
have you ever been caught dancing when
you thought no one was watching oh yeah
oh yeah have you ever tried to roll your
eyes so far
just to see if they could really get
stuck
no right now but i'm gonna try
immediately after
that won't get stuck have you ever
played a practical joke that you regret
pulling on someone
no i'm not
i don't do jokes i don't do pranks
are you streaming live right now
no this is a video idiot are you ugh god
damn it
yeah
if i told you that i was watching you
play this game right now would you
believe me well no because i'm recording
it no
if you've left a comment for me at any
point in time i've read your words does
this bother you
no
if you've left a comment for me does it
make you feel positive that i paid
attention to what you've taken the time
to write
wait my brain is trying to
no i haven't but also i haven't left a
comment
do you understand that no matter what i
appreciate you no i don't understand
that i don't understand that i really do
oh sure okay all right mr bloodstains
all right mr murdered all right mr skull
uh no he's afraid of snakes no do you
believe in magic no
have you cried in the last month yes
do you have a hero no no i'm not much
for hero types
do you typically learn from your
mistakes i'd like to think so but then
again i make a lot of mistakes but i do
learn from them eventually
do you enjoy outdoor activities i'm in
i'm a home buddy
although i do have a i hope to go out
camping or uh solo backpacking that's
what i want to do
would you consider yourself to be lazy
okay
i'm not i know i'm not i work a lot even
if i say i'm lazy and i've said that
many times i
i know for a fact i'm not no
do you sometimes find it difficult to
stay motivated uh sure i think everyone
does
do you put the needs of others before
yourself
no
not
always but sometimes but um
i don't think i do that's not what we're
talking about knees right i i like to
help people i'm gonna say considering
it's like an open-ended question
sometimes i do
sometimes i don't but if it's a
situation where someone i care about
like of course absolutely i'm gonna put
their need first
yeah
i think i do sometimes it's not always
but
when there is a need of someone else i
would gladly put them before me so yes
would your family and friends describe
you as kind i think so yeah have you
ever cheated in a relationship no
have you ever been cheated on yes
would you consider yourself to be
judgmental
no i think i'm open-minded i try not to
no i don't think so
i see i see
do you
are you a hero to someone else
not all heroes work
i guess
probably do i love animals sure
have you ever found a family member on
tinder
no i have not
no
yeah uh meanie
[Laughter]
me neither yeah sure fate okay yeah do
you enjoy drinking alcohol no
are you intoxicated right now no
well that makes one of us
uh very funny fate very funny do you
like the phrase sneaky snake i think
i've said sneaky snake a lot in my
videos sneaky snake that snake is sneaky
so
i think yeah i like that phrase are
these questions a bit strange to you
sure are you have a vivid imagination
yes it's one of my
best qualities maybe
do you feel uncomfortable in large
social settings
not really but also because i'm an
introvert right and the weird thing
about me is that i'm not uncomfortable i
would just rather be somewhere else but
i have a knack for being able to fit in
in large social settings so actually no
i just prefer solitude but not i don't
feel uncomfortable no
would you consider yourself to be
anti-social
um
introvert doesn't always mean
anti-social i don't think i'm
anti-social either i like hanging out
with people i like hanging out with my
friends i like socializing yeah so i'm
not anti-social no you hold a grudge for
long periods of time no and this is
actually something that me and my dad
kind of have very much in common he was
he would have get angry at something but
he was able to let it go i'm very
it's very easy for me to let things go
so no
have you ever urinated in public
i mean i'm sure everyone has because
everyone's been a baby trick question
[ __ ] yes do you like pineapple on your
no i'm not a heathen would you consider
yourself to be selfish if i was being
perfectly honest with myself no a lot of
times i think i am with my time but i
think because i think i am i'm not
actually so no
do you think you've got a big ego oh
yeah
look at who you're talking to here
it's me
markiplier yeah would you consider
yourself kinky no
would you consider yourself to be
religious no
would you consider yourself to be
temperamental
not anymore no actually i think i'm
when it comes to the average i don't i
think i have a very even temperament you
asked me this 10 years ago the answer
would have been no no no no no no no
[ __ ] it no
[ __ ] you no yes it would have been yes
and i know a lot of you probably think
of me in rage games but i've done a lot
of work in my life to try to quell the
burning rage inside of me so oddly
enough no
if you had to kill someone to save your
own life but you knew they didn't
deserve it would you do it all right
okay i had to kill someone to save my
own life like i am going to die
if i don't kill this person so they've
got some kind of a weapon on me i've got
a weapon on them it all depends on the
reason that they would do it but i think
i'm a good enough person that they
wouldn't have any real justification for
trying to kill me so
sorry pal you're going down yes
interesting i mean look i'm being honest
here i think even my survival instinct
would kick in at that point would you
sacrifice your own life for a complete
stranger
in thinking of ever right ever
i could think of a lot of situations
where i wouldn't do this
but if i can think of at least one where
i would it would have to be a situation
where
i was in a it's a trolley problem it's a
trolley problem right but it's like a
deadly trolley problem you're on the
other track god you know i think a lot
of people have done this where they
imagine scenarios where you're like
flying your ship up into the
independence day alien mothership you
know and you're like for
honor and glory and then
yeah i mean for considering how much i
imagined my heroic end
i think i have to answer yes if it's
heroic enough yeah i think i would
there'd be at least one situation there
would be at least one many that i
wouldn't but there would be one
have you ever been inside of a burning
building
i have been inside of a fire fighter
uh like training compound and
technically there was a fire in there
i don't think that qualifies though have
i
no yes no no i don't think i have
have you ever been to a funeral yes if
you could attend your own funeral before
you died would you take the opportunity
to do so
no spoilers come on
nah
i'm good oh god
we did so many funerals
ah but no i wouldn't do that if you
could see into the future but we're told
that it would only reveal the absolute
worst of what's in store for you would
you still look
yeah i'm not
yeah why not
yeah why not if you had the power to
stop time would you use it to do
something you know you shouldn't
[Music]
oh was thinking rob a bank and i was
like i probably would but then i went
like oh
ah would you do it okay
i'm gonna honestly say
if you're thinking about
that then no way in hell
i'm gonna go no
you sick [ __ ]
no
but then again like the time travel in
general is
is forbidden and messing with the past
is probably knowing i shouldn't do
something and i would totally do that
let's see if you had the power to remove
one person from earth never to return
again would you use it zoom
yeah sure you know
i mean do i only get this once
depends on the person right but again
there's many people that i wouldn't do
this to
but there's probably someone that would
deserve it you know what i mean and i
can think of a few right off the top of
my head
yeah
if i told you that i understand you
better than you understand yourself
would you believe me there's no way in
[ __ ] hell fate bring it on [ __ ] i
don't believe you for a second if
someone threatened to kill you would
your first response be to react in
violence
um
god it depends on how quick i need to
react right so someone's
threatening to kill me
let's say the threat is serious right i
don't think my first response would be
to act and violence because i would need
to evaluate how valid that threat would
be
so no if someone's like i'm gonna kill
you ah just come
off off planet you go i i don't think my
first instinct would be to respond with
violence assess the situation with a
levelhead and then violate violence
innate violence
no as a strain if a stranger stole money
from you to support their drug addiction
would you forgive them if they apologize
to you i mean yeah sure
honestly if they came up to me and
apologized and said that they stole it
to support their drug addiction of
course
i'd forgive them if they did it again
i'd be less forgiving yeah i think i
would
if a family member said that something
nasty about you behind your back would
you confront them about it directly i
don't know if anyone in my family would
but yeah i'm kind of a direct person yes
if you had to eat raw squirrel brains
for three days to stay alive would you
do it
give me them brains
[Laughter]
to stay alive yeah if i'm trapped on an
island the only food is a bucket of
squirrel brains but i'm going to be
rescued in three days guess who's eating
squirrel brain
yeah if you woke up tomorrow and none of
your family members remembered who you
were would you choose to leave and start
a new life
okay
i don't live with my family so i don't
think that this really qualifies so i'm
going to extend it if no one on earth
remembered who i was
would i start a new life yeah of course
oh unless it's asking like would i try
to reconnect with them i mean you'd have
to leave start i'm all for starting over
it was this question yeah give me any
chance to start a new life if a homeless
man was clearly sick freezing and
utterly miserable in the rain would you
be willing to give him your clothes and
mock home naked yeah
i mean then i would be utterly miserable
but at least i wouldn't be dying you
know dude give me any excuse to be naked
what kind of question is this yeah i'd
do it
if someone accidentally hit you in their
car but you suffered no injuries would
you still be upset with them it's an
accident i wouldn't be upset if it was
an accident in the first place uh no
have you looked for any hidden meanings
or messages within these questions no i
honestly know maybe you should have been
and maybe you should shut up
are you wondering if there's a deeper
meaning to all this other than simply
answering question after question
no i know your games i know your games
there's no deeper meaning to any of this
no
miracles happen every day do you agree
no
umbrellas aren't worth lugging around
and you don't mind getting radon d i
never carry umbrellas even if i know
that it's gonna be raining but that's
more me being forgetful than anything i
don't mind getting rained on
yeah sure
red is a pretty color than pink do you
agree ooh
cutting right to the quick
ooh
okay so i like red but it's actually not
my favorite color i think i talked about
this before i think pink is a pretty
prettier color
actually i don't know
as much as i love a good pink mustache
like if i was looking at something and
it was red versus if it was pink
prettier
red can be prettier reds can really like
evoke a lot of sensations and feelings
and whatnot and i think that it has the
potential i'm expanding the definition
of pretty here if i was just going like
pretty as in like oh that's pretty you
know
maybe pink
i'm gonna go with red
for the blood
anyway that's a real conundrum for worf
stash here why is this the one that's
getting me ah what if i think is
prettier okay if i saw
pink
pink
red
as an old coffee mug prettier prettier
prettier well this is sparkly so it's
kind of biased but
prettier prettier prettier prettier
prettier
i think you know i'm gonna go pink i'm
worth stashing it up here
[Music]
do you ever feel like a plastic
i honestly know but i wish i could
imagine that yeah i wish i could feel
that no eating in front of people can be
awkward do you agree
no
i've eaten in on a livestream it's not
awkward maybe the way i used to hork
food down but no
i don't think so
rings used as a ceremonial wedding gift
are so outdated do you agree
it's not a wedding gift it's kind of
like a core
thing in weddings for the most part
i'm gonna go with no actually because i
think your definition of wedding gift is
a little strange no did you realize that
the first letter of the last six
questions combined spells up word murder
i don't believe you
do you know why that is i don't care no
does it make you slightly uncomfortable
no you're not gonna do nothing are you
gonna start paying closer attention to
what you may have gotten yourself into
not at all
do you realize it's too late to turn
back now that i have all the options
i'm here where are you
that's fine do you hear someone in your
room
[Music]
no
do you see the shadows closing in
no you can't see those closing in idiot
shadows and absence of white and no
do you feel like you're being
watched yes
did you look around your room a moment
ago yeah sure
you like long walks on the beach
actually no
do you enjoy giving gifts to people yes
have you ever felt like giving up on
life no
do you love your life your family do you
love your family more than you love
yourself
[Music]
i love myself pretty hard
i think you always to go this one you
know i think i think i got it anyway
i love my family i'd do anything for him
i die for him so
but i do love myself but it's a lot of
love i got a lot of love to give you
know but i'm gonna say i put them above
me
yes
do you have a best friend who's clearly
better than the rest of your friends
do you think there's some kind of
conspiracy behind the coronavirus no
do you believe that you're human
yes
if you could turn invisible but you
could never be visible ever again once
you decided to use your power for the
first time would you use it no
no i've seen hollow man no
if you knew someone was about to rob a
convenience store but you knew that they
were doing it to feed their family would
you stop them no
no well i might
buy them something if i knew all that
but i'm not gonna stop them if
you know if i knew that right then and
there if you were stranded on a remote
island with a stranger and you were both
starving to death but you found a secret
stash of food that they didn't know
about would you share with them
yeah cause then when i'm when if i eat
it all myself i'm gonna be all
how are they not gonna know number one
but then i'm gonna be fat and slow and
when they get desperate i'm gonna be all
slowed down they're gonna murder me and
eat me i might as well share it and then
eat them afterwards
i'll get them first i'll fatten them up
it's not it's not
it's not sharing
it's preserving the food
uh yeah i would share
for many reasons if you could turn into
an eagle for one year but you wouldn't
be able to turn back into a person until
that one year had passed would you do it
god i don't want to be no bird
maybe if it was a day sure but a year
what do i'm gonna get shot or eaten or
another eagle's gonna i don't i never
went to eagle school
i don't know how to be an eagle i need
another he was gonna try to [ __ ] me or
fight me i'm not gonna be able to deal
with that i'm good no i wouldn't do it
if you had the opportunity to earn
riches beyond your wildest dreams by
fighting a grizzly bear to the death
using nothing but a machete and an army
helmet would you do it i'm assuming i'm
naked behind besides this look
put your riches away you give me an
opportunity to fight a grizzly bear to
the death that's how i imagine going out
please tell me we can compound this with
saving a random stranger you know i'm
just tromping through the woods naked
with a helmet and a machete and i hear
someone crying for help and i'm like
it's my time
that grizzly's gonna get it and i fight
the yeah absolutely give me that [ __ ] if
you had to pick one basic food item to
eat exclusively for an entire year would
you choose potatoes potatoes are goddamn
versatile and i saw the martian sure you
can cook up potatoes a whole bunch of
different ways yeah sure
if pizza screamed in agony every time
you bit into a piece would you still
continue to eat pizza dude if any food i
eat is screaming in my face i ain't
eating it kill it first
and then i eat it
but i'm not eating that pizza that
pizza's messed up
if your best friend got bit in the
genitals by a highly venomous snake and
the only way to save their life was to
suck the venom out of the genitals would
you do it to save them
it's like that tick tock
like i'd do it
i'd suck that venom right out
i'd give you that glop
yeah yeah the answer is yes if if it was
to save their life i'm sucking it out of
any part of their body i i'm not gonna
be i'm not gonna see my friend die in
front of me because i was too afraid to
suck their dick
present it to me friend i'll get there
first i'm gonna preventively suck just
in case you may not have known that
there was a snake around you may not
even have known you got bit
could happen i'll save you anyway
of course of course i am of course was
that question difficult to answer no
not at all do you feel mortal
yes it would be weird if i didn't
you enjoy loud music no
you feel awkward when you dance in front
of others
i mean kind of honestly not really i
guess kind of there are situations where
i i don't want to dance i think i gotta
go with yes if there's even like a
little bit of like hesitation i gotta go
with yes
do you suffer from any anxiety disorder
no do you ever feel depressed
i'm sure everyone does sometimes yeah
sometimes you're not alone
that's what i just said beat you to the
punch do you ever feel do you feel
relaxed right now yeah sure
do you think you've been have a guardian
angel watching over you no do you ever
hear your name being called when no one
could have called it
i've once or twice i've had like when
i'm just waking up i i swear i've had
this happen yeah i think so
like auditory hallucinations i'm gonna
take special notes of that one okay sure
do you always look both ways before
crossing the road yes and just earlier
today i was going to the store and i
looked both ways and i thought about the
fact that i always look both ways so
actually yes do you wash your hands
every day yes do you ever feel
uncomfortable using public restrooms god
yeah you ever seen the [ __ ] splosions in
some of those bathrooms yeah is winter
your favorite season nah fall
do you know anyone named josh uh josh
peck
are you wondering why that last question
is relevant no
are you allergic to any animals not that
i know of
have you ever thought about an animal in
a sexual way
okay that all of you are thinking about
that pokemon thing
you shut up those aren't real it's all
fake so i'm answering no here i don't
want to hear any lip from any of you i
don't want to hear a peep out of you i
don't want to hear nothing
that ice cream cone was sexy damn
i'm a no no legitimately no
have you ever been in love yes would you
consider yourself to be artistic yes
would you consider yourself to be
dominant in day-to-day life i'm [ __ ]
dumb in this day i'm i'm on top with
this day what does this mean
okay i'm gonna go yes because i feel the
confidence flowing through the the dom
energy flowing through me you feel that
you've gotten too much time on your
hands god no
can you be easily intimidated by others
no
are you easily excitable
what is yes
no
yes no yes i have adhd
you enjoy solving complex problems yes
sometimes you have a difficult time
reacting yeah sometimes would you
consider yourself to be high maintenance
nah pretty easygoing do you trust easily
yeah i think i do would you consider
yourself to be an honest person yeah i
think i do
have you ever told a lie oh god yeah
have you ever lied to your best friend
oh [ __ ] yeah have you ever lied to your
family oh my god yeah have you lied
about answers during this question no
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you
are you wondering why all these
questions have to do with lying nah not
really
this is all very useful information oh i
bet i'd like some useful information
about why there's so much blood behind
you are you a people pleaser
not really i like pleasing people but
i'm not a people pleaser no not in that
sense you enjoy being the center of
attention yeah don't mind it do you feel
like you've gotten a good sense of humor
i've gotten funnier but sometimes i'm
really unfunny but i always make myself
laugh which is the most important thing
yes
you frighten easily
cue the markiplier jump scare
compilation
[Applause]
yeah i think i've written easily
that's pretty pathetic
[Music]
i've heard that exact music before
well that was i wonder what that was
about
yeah me too that's probably a good place
for us to stop the simple segment of our
questionnaire and move on to the more
gritty questions okay the next section
of questions will not be yes or no
answers the next portion of our session
will be filled with various scenarios
that put you smack dab in the middle of
a vital choice making
we'll see how well you handle your
options as you delve deep into each
scenario
remember the key to all this is to
answer honestly okay cool let's get
started
i'm kind of curious what this is gonna
be
you're home alone it's dark and it's
storming outside all of a sudden there's
a knock on your bedroom door someone's
in your house
what do you do i've played a game just
like this
[Music]
okay so it's dark i'm home alone it's
dark and it's storming outside there's a
knock on my bedroom door okay if they're
okay i did i thought that was door
bedroom door i'm grabbing bed knife and
then i'm grabbing bedspear and i am due
wielding that [ __ ]
okay i'm glad i'm the closest item that
can be used as a weapon if someone's in
my house a bed knife and bedspear are
going to be unsheathed
very interesting choice yeah what would
you do fling the door open as wide as
you can i don't think so you meet a
homeless woman on the street she asks
you for money if you find it within
yourself to give her all the spare
change you have just as you do a
homeless man approach is asking if you
can spare some change
i mean i tell the man i got no change
left well i'm not i'm not gonna ask that
man to get anything from the woman what
else can i do i'm not gonna lie i'm not
gonna make someone else look that's just
the way it'd be
i guess it said all spare change like i
know nothing left to offer really now
yeah
both your mother and your father fall
incredibly ill to a life-threatening
disease and there's only enough medicine
and facilities to save one of your
parents and time is of the essence what
do you do well
this is lucky for me because
i only got my mom so i think i think i
i think
i gotta gotta i gotta get out of jail
free card on this one yeah good
good no my mom i'd pick you anyway mom
don't worry i'd pick you anyway don't
stress
mom
that doesn't surprise me
it doesn't surprise me either if we're
being honest here you find a case of
money tucked away inside a dumpster
inside there's ten solid gold bars and a
vial of mystery liquid under the violet
there's a note that says the cure for
cancer
oh
what's the relevancy of the gold bars
let's see turn the case into
professional entities so they can
utilize it keep the gold bars but give
away the cure to cancer keep the cure to
cancer but give away the gold bars keep
everything in the case for yourself to
use
what professional entity is
is ready to accept this number one and
i'd be so confused as to why there were
gold bars
unless the gold bars it was some kind of
like there was something about the gold
that was causing uh this is what i would
think because i'd be so confused as to
why there were gold bars in that case
why would you just put 10 gold bars in a
case with a vial with the cure for
cancer unless it was somehow related to
the cure for cancer if if there's a
[ __ ] box
with
10 gold bars and a vial then i'm not
[ __ ] with it if it says that's a cure
for cancer on it i ain't [ __ ] with
anything in that box i am finding that
professional entity and i'm giving them
everything 10 gold bars
way a lot a lot a lot but there would be
a reason and i would be too paranoid to
not
leave everything in that case so i'm not
saying i'm not greedy enough to take
those 10 gold bars because that's 10
gold bars but also i would be too
paranoid that it had something to do
with the gear i'm turning it all in i'm
not going to be responsible for the cure
to cancer going expiring or going
spoiled or going bad because i took the
gold and everyone would look at me i'd
be too paranoid turn it in
get it off my hands i don't want it
i don't want it
turn it in what a wasted opportunity
says you that gold probably had
something to do with it maybe it wasn't
gold how would i even know it was gold
i'm sorry i know i shouldn't judge look
you're dumb you jump to conclusions it
might not even been gold it might have
been some special animal elmo elmo that
looks gold or molecule or something that
that's the cure not the vial
i don't know you're stuck alone inside
your house and you're starving to death
you've completely run out of food and no
one is coming to save you for weeks the
only potential source of food around you
is your family pets
what
do you do okay
the question is would i eat chica and i
cannot i would not want to live a life
where i had to eat chica i would not
want to walk out of that situation
knowing that i ate chica i'll starve if
i die first and chica eats me that's
fine i'm okay with that
totally valid if honest honestly
very cool
but i'm not eating chica there's no way
in hell
no
no no i would not continue to starve
why am i not surprised i don't know
your neighbor's home is on fire a
blazing inferno among smoke emits from
the windows you hear screams for help
coming from within but you can't see
past the flames no one else is around in
sight what do you do
holy [ __ ] okay call the fire department
keep my distance start shouting for help
and searching for someone nearby run
into the burning home to try to rescue
anyone you can
walk away there's nothing you can do
this is a tough one
because like the logical side of me
knows that it's very stupid to run into
a birding building no matter what it's a
bad idea you literally couldn't have a
worse idea than running into a birding
building with no protection no suits
it's just a bad idea
and yet
i
like i don't think i have a hero complex
but maybe i'm just like overly confident
in my ability to
survive it i think i would weirdly
because i know that's a terrible idea
logically everything about that your
chance of surviving if it's like a
blazing inferno as it says yeah i would
i think i would
i would i wouldn't want to know that
someone died and i could have done
something
hmm
yeah i think i would
god and i know that's a terrible idea
yeah
you like that i don't like that
i don't like that
i don't like that your fastest leaf in
your bed when you're awoken by a sound
like a woman's muffled cries from
somewhere in your room you quickly
realize it's coming from under my bed
if i'm asleep in my bed number one my
bed's on the floor right so if someone's
under my bed they're under the ground
right but let's imagine that i'm in a
place where my bed is
up so there's under my bed i'm hearing a
woman's muffled cries coming from under
my bed okay i immediately look under the
bed hide under the covers and wait
patiently verbally call out and ask
who's in my room jump out of the bed and
run out of the room immediately okay see
how here's the thing there is a muffled
cry of a woman coming from under my bed
i'm looking under that thing but there's
no option here to grab bed knife wait
i'm looking under that you telling me
you hear a muffled woman crying under
your bed and you're not gonna look
you're gonna wait on your covers no
you're gonna call out and ask who's in
my room no you jump out of bed run out
of the room immediately no there's a
[ __ ] something
under your bed
you look under the bed look under the
bed
hmm
with bed knife a man in a fancy suit
approaches you while you're walking down
the street he pulls a watch from his
pocket and hands it to you he claims
that when the watch stops ticking it
marks the moment your time runs out on
this earth what do you do
okay take the watch thank you for the
gift decline the offer for the watch and
keep watching tell him that he needs
professional help and keep assistance
telling you already got three of them as
a toy in your happy meal i'd take the
watch yeah
my very own
countdown hey that helps me plan
no better motivator than looking at that
bad boy
i mean you could make one for yourself
already with the average lifespan and
you could just look at that i'm sure
there's an app for that and if there's
not someone should make it i'm going to
get one i will get one that would be
cool i bought the cursed casa big week
of weeks of your life poster and there's
not as
not as many weeks as you think there are
so i'd take it yeah
would you now yeah i would buddy yeah
would
momento mori you're sitting at home
playing a game on your pc when all of a
sudden someone grips and squeezes your
shoulder firmly from behind what do you
do
i jump and scream
oh jump and turn around yeah god spin
with a vicious elbow whoever's behind
you tell him to squeeze harder
[Laughter]
all right so here's the thing
i know for a fact that if someone grips
and squeezes my shoulder firmly like
this
that better be amy and if anyone has a
reason to do that it's either amy or
like i'm being arrested or i'm being
murdered right so as much as i would
like to just say i jump up and turn
around which is probably what i do
because you give me the option here
and because i always have a camera
showing me what's behind me
and also this this prank has been pulled
oh man i really want to answer this but
would it be an honest i've been very
honest this whole time okay here's the
thing though amy's done this before i'm
i'm in my room playing a game and then
suddenly
you know i'm not even in this room i've
been on the couch and then suddenly i
fill this
i'm thinking it's amy and i've asked for
a shoulder passage before so i i can
honestly say this one because it's
happened and i've done this
ha it's true it actually is true
you're sitting in the bathtub trying to
relax when a hand emerges from the water
what
jump out of the bathroom run as fast as
you can kick the hand and try to keep it
away from you give it a firm
hitch push it under water and hope you
get some free hand action okay all right
i can't i can't worm my way out of this
one i'm not giving it a firm handshake
i'm getting the [ __ ] out of there
there's no way that could be me that's
never happened to me so i'm jumping out
and running
clever yeah
you get out of you get out of bed and
immediately fall down into a deep dark
hole a man is standing above you looking
down telling you to put lotion on your
skin while he watches what do you do
all right so i am in a hole someone
tells me to put lotion on my skin
actually no this is what i would say ask
if you'll come down and help apply the
lotion because
honestly i'm in a [ __ ] up situation
right but one of the strategies to get
out of that is get him close enough so
that i can punch him in his nerds
and his nose
so yeah i'll say this i would honestly
say this
smart choice yeah i know
you're sitting at home alone and all of
a sudden your door slams shut you see it
before your very eyes and you know that
no one is home and it couldn't have been
a gust of wind what do you do i've had
this happen and it's always wind
it's always wind
but that being said i do go to the door
and i open it
that's what i've done
because my brain would just be like
it must have been wind so i would go
open it because if someone is there i do
want to know now that being said look
for weapon is
kind of a good instinct but
i've done this before when the door
suddenly slams shut and i go open it to
confirm that it was wind
i like that you would someone you've
known for many years but have no
attraction to you tells you that they've
had a massive crush on you for a long
time
what do you do
well i'm flattered but i'm not
interested just the way it is
ah so you're one of those types yeah
would you want to say something about
[ __ ] i'm not attracted to you either so
shut up your dog starts randomly barking
into the darkest corner of your living
room there doesn't appear to be anything
there but your dog insists on escalating
to growls what do you do try to calm
your dog down by petting them stand and
stare at the corner see if anything
moves walk up to the corner extend your
hand to feel for anything walk out of
the room and ignore it i would stand and
stare i would i trust chica's judgment
she's dumb a lot of the times but i
would i would i would give it a good
look there is there is one case when i
won't name names i won't name who this
is
but chica's the sweetest dog right she's
the sweetest dog in the world someone
came over that was visiting and chica
peed on the ground when approaching the
person she usually she runs up to anyone
and like is the most lovable but she ran
up to this person
and peed right on the ground and this
was post being potty trained and it's
not like this person had ever done
anything to deserve any suspicion
but i will admit i was suspicious you
know
i was a little suspicious but anyway i
would stand and stare
i'm taking note of that of course you
are you see a massive spider in your
room the size of your hand what do you
do
good god grab something bigger to smash
i mean if
i'm sorry bud look there's a shirt i've
i've rescued some spiders i've sent them
outside tried to do that but sometimes
that thing gonna die oh well maybe not
if i saw it was like a terrain i don't
think actually i would i'll try to
capture it alive you know i if it okay
because if it's as big as my hand that's
real big i would almost be afraid to
fight it and i would think that my
chances might be better if i captured i
would capture it
your closest family member tells you
that they're a serial killer what do you
do
my
mom or my brother
probably my brother if they honestly
said to me that they were a serial
killer number one it would it would
change everything i would know about
them and it would make me question
absolutely everything that ever happened
but i would need undeniable proof that
they were not just joking with me right
tell them you didn't want to know any
more details turn them into the
authorities ask them information so you
can help them stay out travel try to
convince them that they need help so why
are they telling me it's the question
right if it's my closest family member
and they are a serial killer like they
have murdered 10 plus people and i
believed them i would try to you know i
couldn't help it like the relationship
is like that close
that you can't just like turn them in
immediately i would eventually of course
but i would try to like convince them to
turn themselves in
first and if they didn't do that
then i would turn them in but i would
try to at least convince them first
because they're talking to me right so
of course something's happening unless
i'm next
maybe i am but i'll i'll i'll take that
risk that'll suck and i i think
this scenario probably has happened to
some people out there but i was i think
i would try to convince them
if you found out that you only had one
day left to live what would you do
wasn't this in the last one tell
everyone that i love them be happy not
sad do something insane crazy and not
tell anyone at all just ask you just
nothing spend time on my own away from
others
i'm kind of split between these two not
tell anyone at all just ask is act as if
nothing changed or spend time on my own
away from others i definitely wouldn't
tell anybody and i wouldn't do anything
crazy i would not tell anyone and then i
would i wouldn't spend time completely
on my own but i i don't think i would
tell anyone i think i would act as if
nothing changes but you know i would
be doing things like some things getting
my affairs in order and you know writing
down i would write down a lot write down
a lot of my thoughts and my ideas
i'd probably be just writing as much as
i could
and that'd be it
i don't think so
all right then
if one of your pets started speaking to
you and told you that they've got a dire
warning that they were going to die if
you didn't let them eat all the ice
cream in the freezer what would you do
okay first of all
chica starts speaking to me i'm gonna
have the most successful youtube channel
in the world no one's got this beat
most popular instagram account most
popular tick tock account i've got it
made
you can have all the ice cream you want
slowly down i'm obviously too iowa i
don't get high give them all the ice
cream they can handle don't give them
nice cream you're not gonna fall for
that one assure them that you'll protect
them and they won't die ah they're
getting the ice cream and i'm gonna
record it go for it don't get the
chocolate one but you can have it i
don't even have any chocolate one they'd
be fine oh lovely yeah
if all of a sudden you could start
hearing other people's thoughts and the
person next to you was thinking about
mugging you and stealing your money what
would you do take pre-emptive action and
beat them up first tell me you don't
think mugging you is a good idea get
away from them as quickly as possible
ignore it you don't know that you aren't
just hallucinating i mean kind of this
one but also
i'm gonna get away from them as quickly
as possible
yeah but also i can now read thoughts
which is interesting your best friend
comes to you and tells you that they
just accidentally killed someone and
they don't want to go to prison what do
you do tell them they're on their own
you want to ride them out try to
convince them to turn themselves in
report them to the authorities help them
hide the body okay
accidentally killed someone i'm not
going to help them hide the body because
that's implicating me
on a crime maybe i don't even want to be
in the investigation i'm not going to
report them directly because it's kind
of one of those things where i would
talk to them first i would convince them
that they had if it was an accident then
they have nothing to be afraid of like
if it was an honest true accident and
it's not even that they shouldn't have
anything to be afraid of but like they
should own up to that and if it's an
accident if they didn't intend it at all
then they need to come forward because
it did they need to come out with that
otherwise it looks like they did it on
purpose like telling them they're not on
their own i would convince them to turn
themselves out
oh yeah you're driving in your car and
you accidentally runs them over you're
pretty sure that they're okay but the
fact that their head is clearly detached
from their bodies suggests that it's
probably wishful thinking what do you do
um call your best friend tell me you
don't want to go to prison turn yourself
into the authorities drive away try to
hide the bug turn myself in
i just ran someone over i just ran
something over their head is over there
i'm turning myself in
well you're watching me of course so
many people are interesting how that
played out i think it's time we move on
to the next portion
the following question shall be asked of
you are would you rather stop questions
imagine you've got a gun to your head
and absolutely must choose the answer no
matter how uncomfortable that may be
okay
let's get started shall we would you
rather be loved by all or feared by all
fear is pretty cool love is pretty cool
i loved sure
would you rather never get angry or
never get jealous
um i'm not really a jealous person but i
don't like it when i'm angry i already
kind of take steps to do this so i'd say
never get angry
would you rather be held in high regard
by your parents or my friends
yeah my parents my
freudian slip probably but i think my
friends but i am
happy to have my parents
i guess parents but parents are always
proud of you
parents i guess i got to go parents
would you rather live in space or in
space
would you rather donate your body to
science or donate your organs to people
who need them people who need them they
can have them would you rather go to
jail for five years for something you
didn't do or get away with something
horrible you did but always live in fear
of being caught
god just the idea of going to jail for
something i didn't do would never sit
right with me live in fear of getting
caught can you imagine
and that happens to people people go to
jail for things they didn't do well i'll
live in fear of getting caught
would you rather work at a horrible job
you hate to retire comfortably in 10
years would you rather have your dream
job but have to work until the day you
die that's
that's what i'm doing right now
hopefully if things go right yeah if
it's a dream job it's not even work
would you rather ever shirt you'll ever
wear be to be somewhat itchy or only be
able to use one ply toilet paper you
fold one ply toilet paper it becomes two
ply you fold it again four apply you
know just fold it i've been using one
flight toilet paper for a lot of my life
and i think not by choice you know
whenever i go out
people have to deal with that one ply
i'm not gonna do an itchy shirt
would you rather have skin that changes
colors depending on your mood or have
tattoos appear on your body that depict
what you did yesterday that sounds dope
as hell it would encourage me to live
cool life and and when i have a cool
adventure the tattoos would appear on my
body that's amazing and i'm sure one day
my like me jerking off might appear
there but hey
that'd be cool i don't if i don't like
that part the show and i just cover that
up that'd be great would you rather [ __ ]
every time you orgasm
every time you see a dog
i'll take orgasm shits for 5 000 alex
if your partner switched bodies with one
of your parents and the only way to get
them to switch back was to have sex with
one of them
would you rather have sex with your
partner in your parents body or have sex
okay good the choices are what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you no seriously what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you just answer the
question oh my god sex with my parent in
my partner's body sex with my partner in
my parents body
god
there's no logic in your way out of this
one there's pure and simple no lodging
your way out of this one it's just no
matter what happens
it's [ __ ] up so you just have to go
the least mentally scarring route
[Music]
i've got it okay
i've saw i've solved it you haven't
solved [ __ ] i've solved the problem i
choose
sex with partner parents body because
you can put on a blindfold
no one will say anything
because you can remove yourself from it
and then
because i there's no way in hell
that i would ever do the sex with parent
and partner's body because
there's no like
x no way
not happening but this is an impossible
situation right so you just gotta
minimize
how much it'll [ __ ] with your head right
so you have to blindfold up and just
that's the solution
partner parents body
that's the solution
it's it's bad either way it's worse the
other way i think there's no way that it
couldn't be worse that way yeah i gotta
i gotta choose that one that one had no
bearing on your results i was just
curious well you're an [ __ ]
i think we've answered enough these
types of questions as i'm sure you'd
agree we're going to end the test with a
series of short final questions giving
simple answers we'll get started now
okay
out of the following options which
number do you like the most uh
three's cool that 11's got two ones
out of the following option what color
makes you feel most relaxed green
out of the following options which
creature are you least comfortable
around uh
scorpions i just don't like them
out of the following options which is
your flavor is your favorite uh
chocolate vanilla peanut butter mint i
do get a lot of things with mint but i
do just love chocolate out of the
following options which do you
personally value the most
uh family friends money freedom
yeah freedom
yeah
now the following options which would
which could you most live without
um
i don't know if i could save money
because i like obviously i have money
i've lived very comfortably so it would
be hypocritical for me to say that i
could live without it i mean i have
lived without it before and it's been no
problem family's too important
friends are too important freedom's too
important honestly money as much as i
joke about how i grew up poor i did in
fact grow up poor without a lot and
so long as you have food
one more you really need
money does allow me to be more creative
and money does bring freedom but
honestly if the question is would i
sacrifice family for money no would i
sacrifice friends for money no would i
sacrifice freedom for money and no
so it's got to go
uh the following options which statement
is the most accurate i am brave i am
caring i am smart i am attractive hmm
i i'm pretty smart i'm damn sexy but i
think
i think i'm brave
that's what i would say about myself i
am caring but i consider myself to be
brave enough to make choices
that other people wouldn't and do things
that other people wouldn't and i think
yes caring i am but
i think i'm brave
i think i am
now the following option which are you
most afraid of living forever losing my
loved ones dying alone dying immediately
after this
um
god this may sound weird
living forever would be a nightmare i've
lost loved ones i've lost that
it's it's not something that like i'm
afraid of but i am but i think everyone
is dying alone doesn't scare me dying
after this test isn't gonna happen
living forever is
is a nightmare
that's terrifying
we're almost finished but i've got one
final question for you
have you ever punched a nun god ah
[Applause]
no but i oh man
they're asking for it now this is like
all this game is to subconsciously
program me to punch a nun but i have not
so no
you really ought to try it sometime it
could really take
all right we're done here i'm through
with you
i'm just going to calculate the real
results very carefully i just don't want
to miss anything important
trying my absolute hardest not to judge
you right now trying to keep this as
professional as possible
aha here we go
based on what you've told me i've come
to a conclusion is what i personally
believe would be in your best interest
to acknowledge set in motion and
accomplish in order to climb the ladder
of happiness in your life
first and foremost i'd like to start
with a blanket statement that everyone
truly needs to hear
something that is taken for granted far
more than anything else in life
something that has such an incredible
unique
irreplaceable value compared to any
other thing on this earth
and that
my friends
is the value of time
time is the most valuable form of
currency you will ever hold in life
you can spend time on anyone doing
anything for any reason
now
time can be spent time can be wasted and
time can be taken away
a time can never be refunded time can
never be earned back and more time can
never be gained
imagine a bank account with all the
money you'll ever get to spend in life
now imagine not knowing how much money
is in your account
imagine going to the store one day to
purchase something you really need and
the cashier tells you i'm sorry but you
can't afford that as a matter of fact
you can never afford anything ever again
we only have so much time and we have no
idea just how much or how little we
truly have before our bank account runs
dry
and the fact that we get to decide and
choose what we spend our time on just
shows you how truly special it is when
someone spends their time on you
so now that we understand the incredible
value of time i'd like to make a
suggestion for you personally on how i
think you'd be best spending your time
in order to achieve what you need most
at this current stage in your life
let's see here
alright this is fairly interesting
you're among the rare few people who
have an incredible amount of untapped
potential and you're not using this
potential to your advantage
i think you need to take a good hard
look at what you invest your time into
and ask yourself if it's really truly
worth it
considering how limited your time
actually is in life are you doing
everything you can to accomplish your
goals before your time inevitably runs
out
because i don't think you are and i
think you know that the only reason i'm
telling you this is because it's what
you need to hear you could be doing such
amazing things
but you aren't spending time focusing on
using those things to your advantage
or improving them enough
you've got a natural neck some real raw
powerful talent but you're either not
working hard enough to harness it or
you're spending your time improving the
wrong aspects of your life and you feel
that deep down
my advice to you is to spend some time
thinking about where you're going to end
up in the next 10 years if you continue
the path you're currently on
if you envision anything other than pure
contentment and happiness at the end of
that 10-year road then you need to start
walking down a different road
once you figure this part out you're
going to be a hell of a lot happier in
life and i think you can already feel
the truth in that
i think you'll be very surprised just
how much of a positive impact this can
have on your life going forward i hope
this information helps you achieve your
goals
your secret word is potential
remember this word
this will come in handy
[Music]
all will be revealed in the next one but
not a single person has been able to
figure out what this entire experiment
is all about yet
you know
you know something's kind of right when
it makes you question things about
yourself because my first instinct when
seeing that was the fact that i've done
things and i've i've had accomplishments
and i've done pretty incredible things
just in the past 10 years you know
because i am coming up on my 10-year
anniversary of doing youtube but in a
way like it's it's right i don't know if
this is all just like [ __ ] as random
things or whatever i don't other
criteria for
thinking this and it's like kind of like
horoscopes it's open-ended and you can
kind of attach your own meaning to it
but god this is the one thing that i've
been thinking about a lot lately is
time i i even said in here that i bought
that kurtz kassad how many weeks you
have in your life poster i
i did units honest with ethan and amy we
did unisonness and it's just like the
biggest thing that's always on my mind
is how much time i have i don't want
unlimited time i don't want more time
i want to use the time that i have to
the best of my ability and a lot of
things that i've been thinking lately
have been making me question
am i using my time effectively am i
doing things and in a lot of ways i am i
am using my time more efficiently but
only because i am asking that and sure
i'm flattered it says i have potential i
i think i'm doing pretty good but what
it's saying is true and i am curious to
see what all this is leading up to in
the third installment which i will do at
this point because i've gone through
these two and i found them to be a fun
fascinating experience so why not keep
going but i do often question if i'm
using my time efficiently i do wonder if
like i think
too much about the right way of going
about something because as much as i do
say like start something and i do think
i live that but there are parts of me in
areas that i want to improve outside of
what i normally do where i question
things and i like oh i gotta find the
most
efficient way and i like i don't
practice what i preach and
you know
time
we just don't have enough
or to look at it a different way
we have exactly as much as we need but
it's not guaranteed that we'll use it
correctly it's never too late
because you don't know what too late is
but it will be too late if you put
everything off until tomorrow
so
i think there's some wisdom in that then
again it's a stupid game that left me on
punching a nun so i'm going to use my
time effectively and i'm going to find a
nun to punch so thank you everybody so
much for watching it'll be a nun that
deserves it if you want to take this
test for yourself link is in the
description let me know what your secret
word was mine was potential my first one
i think was
i forget what it was
you'll remind me thank you and as always
i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
you